die deutsche sondern sind bereits im
interstellaren raum angekommen wollte 1
wird das erste entfernte stern system
schon in rund 40.000 jahren erreichen
gs45 allerdings immer noch in einer
entfernung von 1,6 lichtjahren und die
schwester sonde voyager 2 wird den stern
ross 248 ungefähr zur selben zeit in
einen ähnlichen abstand erreichen die
ersten von menschen geschickten besucher
eines anderen stern systems wenn wir
nicht bis dahin den warp antrieb
erfunden haben aber schon heute können
wir in den orionnebel reisen
wie das gehen soll jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen ja
es sind absolut faszinierende bilder die
uns hier vom orionnebel erreichen
allerdings ist dort kein raumschiff
hingeflogen ist könnte sie auch gar
nicht so schnell bewegen allerdings
liegen uns durch die weltraumteleskope
hubble und spitzer so detaillierte daten
vor so dass jetzt erstmals ein flug
durch den orionnebel simuliert werden
konnte und das ist wirklich der hammer
dass wir von hier aus einen so konkreten
blick in diesen nebel werfen können
immerhin ist der 1344 lichtjahre
entfernt für diese animation lieferte
hubble bilder aus dem sichtbaren
wellenbereich und spitzer aus dem
infrarot bereich der orionnebel befindet
sich in unserer milchstraße und ist ein
entstehungs gebiet für sterne errechnet
hat diese reise ein team unter der
leitung von frank summers vom space
telescope science institute
die reise beginnt im außenbereich des
nebels und führt dann in das zentrum des
nebels hier werden neue sterne geboren
und liegen eng beieinander sie sind auch
für das leuchten des nebels verantworten
durch die ionisierende strahlung der
sterne leuchte der nebel im sichtbaren
bereich und ist so als einziger nebel
mit dem bloßen auge von der erde aus zu
beobachten
die stärkste lichtquelle bietet dabei
das doppelsternsystem täter uhren ist
zäh ich finde es absolut irre
dass wir solche sternen reisen durch
moderne computer inzwischen unternehmen
können
das sind wirklich absolut faszinierende
bilder beeindrucken wie hier die sterne
im nebel verteilt sind und auch wirklich
wahnsinnig schön
ich hoffe dass in zukunft noch öfter
solche fantastischen animationen zu
sehen bekommen das video macht wirklich
appetit auf mehr und weckt auch ein
bisschen sehnsucht hoffentlich
entwickeln wir irgendwann mal so etwas
wie den warp antrieb und können das auch
in wirklichkeit sehen wahnsinn wenn er
solch unglaubliche bilder nicht
verpassen wollte und auch alle anderen
videos dann drücken wir hier ein abo
aufs auge und vergesst nicht den genau
auf die glocke denn nur dann werdet ihr
auch wirklich über neue videos
informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür
drauf klicken das erste foto von erde
und mond auch ziemlich irre
ansonsten bis dann bleibt da